I think the most problematic thing for
me is that the two great passions
intellectual passions of my life are
very hard-nosed analytic philosophy of
mind and cognitive science on the one
hand which is what I started out doing I
was a philosopher and it's still in some
important sense where my deepest heart
is and children and babies on the other
hand and of course that hard-nosed
analytic philosophy of mine philosophy
and generals totally dominated by men
has been a field that's even more
dominated by men than you know
theoretical physics is and of course
anything to do with babies is completely
associated with women so it's been a
real struggle a part of you know half
the time I thought to myself well come
on you don't want to be a woman whose
career is devoted to doing all those you
know will many things with kids and
babies and all that girl stuff right
and another part of me has you know you
should really go and become the analytic
philosopher and show that this is
something that that women can do just as
well and the other part of me says no no
what you should be doing is showing that
all that stuff that everybody you know
treats with without much dignity babies
children they're actually telling us as
much if you pay attention to them there
is deep and profound and is important
and tell us as much about any of the
things that we care about in analytic
philosophy as the you know science and
the things that analytic philosophers
guide philosophers typically pay
attention to so so the whole point of my
career has been to try to take babies
and young children who have been I don't
think it's too much of an exaggeration
to say I've been sort of intellectually
treated with contempt over the years
when I when I was in graduate school one
of the Oxford philosophers when I was
talking about how children could explain
about philosophy turned to me and said
no children about hasn't won but but
never actually speak to one and that's
not totally out of the attitude that
people have had towards babies and
children so what I've tried to do is
take that take that world and show just
how deep and profound and analytic and
rigorous and intellectually serious it
is and has it always been an easy
that hasn't always been an easy road oh
but but I'm glad that I actually tried
to do both of those things and put both
of those things together instead of just
following wanted